I brought I couldn't even imagine
spending on a pair of shoes
so these are
I would move you all the way to the
front though that's my favorite outfit
your outfit looks most expensive
compared to everyone just off the bat
dog this was 30 Thrift twelve dollars
Thrift yeah people who are babes still
always have hella monies all right so
you got to go to the friends I'm gonna
come over here and then gradually sift
back through I like hers I feel like
yeah she's definitely yeah she's well
put everything she's well put I honestly
would put her one if not two okay yeah
you got the black Phantoms on those just
came out so it's true those did just
come out and so you're wearing them then
they're probably not your most expensive
you you can go in front of me go three
right now I feel like the denim tears
those are like 400 pants those are 400
pants he has to be further up right
behind Legacy yeah okay okay I like that
I think this is a good ranking you think
so all right I would put myself ahead of
you go ahead please please I have to go
a little bit more ahead yeah yeah I know
I would keep dealing I keep doing here
yeah okay because I really can't go off
of other information though right we're
going off just Aesthetics because
Aesthetics I mean you're real low-key
everything on my body's free yeah
I feel like maybe someone should be
right here yeah yeah like this do you
think so okay okay
wait why did you move Dylan because he
has a watch on and watches are expensive
so I would move him right here so you
lost okay okay
what do you think about this
I think in terms of looks and what we
can see I think this is very valid it's
fair word
it's super important to keep in touch
with the roots of where things come from
you know for example the Air Force One
uh it got popular because kids in the
hood uh it was known for a long time
it's actually like a cheap sneaker and
so they were putting them in bargain
bins for like 20 bucks for a pair it's
not just what the thing is in this
moment it's everything that's around it
so what do you guys think feel about
reselling
I think you know
um you can make a lot of money from it
reselling Community helps out a lot if
done the right way but there's a lot of
I know negativity you know with the Bots
and everything like that so I mean I
like Bots I actually I develop my own
bot so I've been in the scene uh on the
bot side for a while now and you should
be on the front then
so basically a bot lets you input
different credit cards you run it on
certain sites so each site is different
different Bots do different things they
don't always work every drop it's not as
easy as it seems and it's a big
investment
it's hard for regular people like me I
don't buy I buy everything retail so I
will enter so many Raffles like around
like 20 each drop and I get L's on every
single one because
ruin the sneaker Community but I
understand they need to make their
hustle and make the money these botters
they're getting all the pairs that are
in my size which is kind of frustrating
head of the line man hit the line just
say I don't necessarily agree with this
but that's the biggest sneaker head
that's well if he's collecting if he's
keeping him
I'm sorry I'm telling you a lot as a
sneaker like the UNC fours I think I got
like 40 pairs of those that's why I
didn't get a pair a few of them were for
other people and I didn't keep any of
them so you probably made like let's
just say average maybe three four grand
on a pair of UNC fours right yeah
basically you have a lot of money you
might be sporting on shoes for all we
know but not necessarily I might be
making on botting but I don't
necessarily spend it back on shoes yeah
right now bro okay does anyone have any
ill feelings towards
as a female
I'm sure you can relate smaller sizes
have lesser quantity so it's already
very difficult for us to get it and
usually resell value on smaller sizes
are higher so people like him be taking
all the quantity from us the people who
actually generally would wear the
sneakers and not to just make money when
we put someone that's taken quantity
away from the actual people true
collectors like would we value him as I
mean at the one spot I think that's
invalid what you just said because I'm a
true collector too no no no not like
that I'm saying no I know but I'm saying
you're not necessarily taking away from
collectors because if collector really
wants something they'll just pay for it
it's not cool if it's not expensive I
disagree with that though sometimes some
of the best joints are not the most
expensive ones it's what it means to you
honestly because for me I'm probably the
oldest dude here I was in the first
supreme Warehouse sale in o5 so we lined
up in SoHo I got a pair of SB Delta
Forces no hype around that joint they're
probably not even listed on stockx right
now but I love that pair because of what
it means to me right yeah you know so I
feel like that for me is what a sneaker
head is I kind of want to move him
because he said he's an OG and a lot of
old issues nowadays are worth a lot more
because the market skyrocketed less you
didn't no you said you were at Supreme
though so I assuming if you like that
Supreme stuff I know a lot of the older
Supreme goodies are like worth 10 times
as much as they are back then so I feel
like you got a bunch of old heat that's
now worth a bunch of money I'll be real
I don't even know the prices on some
stuff right now because I just got it
right I got it because this this looked
fire so I have no idea but I'll stand
here for now how do y'all feel about uas
I mean I think they're fine I don't
really care yeah me personally I don't
really care about reps like I get it
shoot the shoe game is crazy now like
your average Joe is not spending 700 on
a parachute fine by me right cool
realistically though if you buy a rep
just don't sell it as real don't try
don't try and make a business that's
scammy yeah because I'll be real there's
some pairs back there that are reps that
I brought out of your like collection
how many of them are reps yeah there you
go it's probably about 20 so I'm happy
to start okay only because you said you
had rep so for all we know I definitely
got real can you guys discuss how you
got into the sneaker headphone okay my
dad's a big sneaker head so all he put
me in was Jordan's and I didn't like it
because it was more of like a guy thing
back then so I thought like everyone's
gonna think I'm wearing guys shoes but
then I bought my first pair in like 2015
and then I was like everyone
complimented me and I was like I like
this so I'm a rapper right I'm an artist
uh and for me it was really through
hip-hop it was yeah it was all for the
culture like going to the warehouse
sales I'm thinking you need to be up
here okay but I personally think I need
to be down a little bit we'll we'll keep
you at number three I would say three
yeah yeah you feel good about that yeah
I went to I went to go to Nike with my
grandmother and I finally got the
Weatherman Foamposites I was the first
ever shoe I got I remember vividly 274
bucks and that was so much money to me
because I was in third grade I should
actually get a shoe like that I still I
still buy a lot I have like around 50
pairs right now but I do like to wear
you know boots more than anything you
have great style so I think you should
be like right here actually my first
shoe when I got um onto the basketball
team was a pair of Derrick Roses and
then basically I started growing my
knowledge I started like obsessing over
just having the better kicks because I
didn't have any Jordans and I didn't
like have the money for it and um
eventually I just slowly started getting
my way up how long have you been
flipping shoes though since 20 since
2015. you're still due to this day yeah
yeah a little bit okay
okay okay but Dylan How many pairs do
you have in your collection
um in my collection okay wait not even
collect inventory inventory yeah how do
you know that I got inventory though the
way you move bro wait yeah
um like over a thousand I definitely put
you ahead of me for sure all right and
then what about you I've got like 150
pairs probably right now I have about
600 so yeah
I'm happy I'm happy to be over here I'm
happy to be with the peasants yeah I
would say you're up a little bit for now
yeah that that sounds right I'd say out
of the 50 pairs I have there's like 30
pairs that like sit on ice because
there's some shoes that I view as like
it's like real estate you know shoes go
up and down I view them more so as like
an asset I personally don't wear it like
most of them I like to wear all my shoes
I would I wear all my shoes too but
there are certain shoes that I wouldn't
wear like if I would ever obtain them
like the Paris dunks or the Nike mags
those are like art pieces those are you
know you see you have the mags okay
[Laughter]
and then there's just you know wear and
tear all days 100 what are your everyday
shoes for me I wear like slides or props
no Leahy Crocs are the best everyday
shoe those were so good right okay I've
been wearing those all year mainly when
I go out I wear a lot I'm like a big
Rick Owens guy so I wear like these
aren't Rick Owens but these are it's
similar but I have you know platform
boots I have a couple Rico and pairs I
have like about four
yeah yeah they're kind of up there yeah
yeah definitely yeah my beaters are
Jordan Ones and Jordan threes my
everyday beaters are the off-white
University
dunks I do beat those I didn't want to
wear them at first but then I was like
I'll just do it
I don't beat them but I wear them a lot
like if we're looking at like who has
the most expensive I'll put her ahead of
me just for beaters right like yes yeah
my my beaters are awful
you're with me I'll put myself okay
we're trying to find the person in my
opinion you should be up a little bit
I'm fine with staying down here you can
go up one okay I feel like the SBS SB
highs or SB lows I got both both but
like majority as below majority are lows
I feel like I should be here
I would say my biggest beater is
off-white Europe oh you got the whites
but he could have got them for retail
though I did not get enough burrito even
if you didn't get them for retail
in the beginning stages but the value on
that alone
right here a second yeah or you can go
you can even go first yeah yeah go first
yeah all right that's a six thousand
five six thousand dollar pair so when he
said it was a a beater I was just like
yeah you're going up front
seventh
Abdel
sixth Natalie oh okay
fifth Lexi oh damn
fourth Alex okay all right we got two
wrongs that's okay I was kind of I was
telling you he's out there I was telling
you guys Jason third
Dylan okay I knew it oh my god oh man
Second Jason C oh dang okay I told you I
was right here
oh I'm wearing a five dollar Nautica
this way is this my books I swear it's
first Jason h yeah I told you
[Music]
so I brought the Travis sales these I
bought for 450 worth around 1200 new I
think I like Loki wear these all the
time like I don't really keep many of my
expensive shoes I just can't bring
myself to keep something that I could
just sell
so I brought the off-white floors
it matches my outfit it was two pairs of
off-white that I had to trade for these
and these are definitely a grill these
are off-white for sales and they their
value is 1 300. so I actually brought
the same
same as him but yeah the sizes are
different so the price is different I
actually got these for like 300 from my
local reseller for brand new they're
going for about 1400 in my size I
brought the original Travis Scott mocha
these are brand new at I believe 22 2500
but I got them for a good deal I think I
got them for like around 1400. for me I
bought a childhood Grill
all right you had to bring them out so
it was these were actually very special
to me because I've always wanted these
as a kid I actually bought them for nine
hundred dollars that's right the value
of these sneakers are now six thousand
dollars brand new and uh you gotta see
the bottle right it's brand new to the
bottom they're pretty clean you know
what I mean so yeah
I'll sell them to you right now how much
4 000. no
all right so for me and there's a long
story behind these so these
boys
so this one um right so when these drops
I was living in China and I was doing
music out there and I was doing work out
there and so my best friend we had a
streetwear line together and so I was
like dude I need these like Nike's gonna
surprise drop these this shit's gonna be
crazy I didn't buy them at Nike and I
didn't buy them through the Nike drop my
boy went and he talked to his people
because he knows the people at the
factory and I've worn these I wear these
for Lunar New Year you know what I'm
saying like I have so to me this is not
only like you know my most valued pair
but I've got so many memories
let's trade right now onset hey as you
know I have the most expensive I don't
think you guys were prepared for this
man I'm gonna pull out a solid gold shoe
I don't know if you guys know what I
have but I've been in the game for some
time so oh
[Applause]
Big Ups that's a brand new rear that
isn't of Nike SB Paris dunk Lowe's
and a size 10 and a half I've owned
these for just shy of a year and a half
now so I paid 81 000 for these last year
and the current value of these is
roughly like 100 to 120 Grand yeah you
know there's only 200 two pairs in the
world but each shoe if you look
ichu is completely different in terms of
the artwork so no pair will look
identical to one of the 202 out there so
every pair left and right is technically
considered one of one right yeah these
are these are very crazy I actually own
two pairs I have a worn one and then
this is the brand but there are certain
shoes that I wouldn't wear like if I
would ever obtain them like a pair of
dunks what do you do for work uh I sell
shoes so I sell very high-end shoes
that's what I do full time I used to
make nine bucks an hour lifting 500
pound couches by myself and uh
eventually I saved up my checks and I
got like my first crazy pair of shoes
which was a pair of off-white Jordans
I've always had a passion for them I
couldn't afford them my parents weren't
lending me money to buy the crazy stuff
that I always wanted so I had to work
for it and eventually that passion
turned into a business which is not what
I do today
foreign
they don't smell like anything I
couldn't even imagine spending that much
on a pair of shoes I'm not even gonna
hold them you can hold them
nah bro that's crazy I applaud you for
buying them thank you for bringing those
here no yeah you flew I mean oh he
brought both I would have these these I
had on my backpack though so these I
didn't put them in my luggage or nothing
I was walking around like you know
securing them I had to make sure
everything was good